and will carrier of course for the golden
knights flipped on by Cody CI and then a
rebound spit out from Eden Hill but he does
cover so it sets up Vegas on the power play
you see 18th in the NHL against the Oilers
kill sixth best in the NHL and they have
been really good in particular during this
winning streak here's Maro enter the circle
fired it on at Skinner he had a guy wide open
to the left of skinners brenon bran on this
unit McDavid off the turnover for tricyle
MC David scores the Oilers strike first
short-handed this at the end of a penley kill
they put out their two stars you hope you have
a tired power play it's just a turnover at
the Blue Line dry Sidle comes off the bench
it creates a two on0 and look at the excitement in
this building erupted there is a ton of Edmonton
Oiler fans here and no chance for Aiden Hill what
a start for Edmonton short-handed with the start
the kill is 45 for 48 you talked about leaning
on the coaching staff Mark Stewart is leading
the penalty kill Martinez shot was kicked out by
Stewart Skinner Cotter wrestled for it Stone holds
it in top of the ccle pass broken up on the way
through Stone retrieves it along the wall spins
it back to the point Martinez across to petrula
seam pass Stone thought about it threw it on net
towards Skinner Mark Stewart is leading the
penalty kill Martinez shot was kicked out by
Stewart Skinner Cotter wrestled for it Stone
holds it in top of the circle pass broken up
on the way through Stone retrieves it along the
wall spins it back to the point it was like the
Stanley Cup hangover didn't exist they knew that
they could lose their jobs at any time and they've
had that feeling before and they just brought it
right from game one it's pretty incredible he's
been completely healthy through four of Seven
Seasons here in Vegas and cter loads one up and
Skinner controls the rebound you hear about it as
a player you're well aware of it but you try and
focus on your process and then if you're Vegas
you're thinking it's not happening here tonight
in our barn you know that's your motivation among
amongst also trying to get your game to where it
needs to be post all start break no matter what
is said by players you do think it is top of mind
on both sides well I think so because you're asked
about it all the time you're well aware of it it's
not a part of your preparation but it definitely
gives you a little motivation on both sides Nick
hag with a one-time that steuart Skinner keeps
out and a big week in this city you can feel
it being here hey just how big it is kulak speeds
ahead and a save hill at the tail end of the Vegas
power play Edmonton leading in over the line M
David for Heyman Hyman with a shot the save by
Hill picked up by W head man's for barbashev
barbashev moves in stops on a dime top of the
circle left it for Maro weaving in Maro had it
poked off his stick petrangelo on the back pedal
toward the net they SC it's nicku on the rebound
tied at one you know Barber Chev Ates this play
waits for his teammates to come up and but watch
Maro drives the middle of the ice collapses the
Oilers that gives Petra Angelo so much time to
pick a spot and the traffic we talked about it
earlier Vegas they're going to be in front of
the golender there's a second opportunity there
Skinner can't see it cleanly was upset above felt
that there should have been a call and behind work
NE run for Holloway and then a bit there and Aiden
Hill oh man in the offensive zone and then they
get it down low and get to work and does it hit
heg stick or the glove of Aiden Hill let's watch
here and it's take stick and nice little read
there facee off control back to kulak plays catch
with d kulak midp Point through the slot bodies in
front loose toward Kan Hill scws out and keeps it
out and again a one face off for the Edmonton
Oilers kulak just gets this in front you see the
traffic by Fogle Kane is in there as well and
Aiden Hill just uses his size to his Advantage
takes that right leg kicks it out and the puck
comes right back to his belly and he's able to
cover that up very good all right so Kaden
corac for slashing and nent Hopkins whipped
one just wide loose for Hyman and Newton Hopkins
was parked in front but Aiden Hill earns a whistle
2 3 seconds into the Oilers power play PS against
on 80 shots and he is battling through everything
here in this hockey game through screens through
traffic you know he gets lost and out of position
but he finds his way back gets make sure he gets
a near post save there on McDavid he was so smart
to try to bank it off him hman for buar pass the
halfway point newon Hopkins now A one- Time board
off the iron off the Left Post on the right side
you think of McDavid you think of nen Hopkins in
the bumper Hyman in front and then you hear that
Bard with as you mentioned the Bard bomb I mean
the weapons are just all over the place dropped
it back McDavid holds on to it stretches It Wide
around Brad and off the shot there heill went
diving across and might have got a piece of it
yeah they sure have little two times give and go
between dry Sidle and McDavid and he'll make the
unbelievable save right here to negate dry Sidle
watch this just get a piece around the wall in
the direction of White Cloud Holloway got it back
to the line and moved for C toward the net bought
off by Aiden Hill a Bice here's McDavid moving in
with Hyman McDavid fired it on at Hill from short
rage nurse from the point locked by Martinez
for Drive SLE along the back door CeCe pinched
skated past it amadio Springs forward he's
got Ron BJ with him amadio off the pads of
Skinner 641 for the golden Knight so four more
minutes for the Oilers Dy tile backand it he'll
makes the stop on a Vander Kane Edmonton he makes
an unbelievable save on Evander Kane who's left
wide open we told you he was busy in the second
and up to the task there now mve moving in it's
coner dragging through the wickets stood up by
Darnell nurse swooping in Stevenson a one timer
scar a save on one end a snipe on the other
Vegas lee Vegas is able to go down the ice
Potter is the one that gets it into the Zone
gets it in deep battles with Darnell nurse
in the corner maintains possession just C
possession here here's Stevenson looking
across the trailer was petrangelo McDavid broke
it up now he moves forward with speed it's drle
back to drle and KT out Bogle had it knock
free amadio to the line AIO at Center Ice
chipped ahead Howen reaches out for it empty
net Carlson set it high off the Stick of Fogle
203 left will to put this one away with an
empty net goal and watch Fogle just come
into your pitcher just get his now petrangelo
shoves it toward the line not out set back in
Martinez ahead for stone now Stevenson with
Carlson skate the stick dles SC to put it on
ice
you know honestly I I think every Vegas player
touched the puck here just calm little close
support into the neutral zone little patience
there by Carlson as Bard tries to force him to
the outside and how fitting is that he's played
a great game his first game back and what a key
goal for him and Mark Stone loved it and the
final seconds TI off and Vegas a streak stopper
tonight on home ICE the Oilers winning streak
ends at 16 one shy of matching the Penguins